this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
check out Squarespace through the link
in the description below more unlimited
its he's a man known to history
literally as the terrible Ivan the
fourth was the first Tsar of Russia the
man who built the iconic symbols
Cathedral and the ruler who defended
Moscow from tartar invasion in Russian
history he's a towering figure behind
perhaps only Peter the Great and Lenin
in how he shapes the nation yes how much
do any of us really know about him
beyond his mistranslated nickname could
he really be as bad as the crazed
wild-eyed caricature of popular history
well no as it turns out Ivan the
Terrible was if anything even more
terrifying
elevated to ruler of Russia when he was
just a boy Ivan showed sociopathic
tendencies from the get-go as a child he
was renowned for torturing small animals
as an adult he had his opponents torn
apart by wild dogs a bloodthirsty king
who killed his own son and created a
feared secret police this is the story
of Russia's century Stalin
[Music]
on August the 25th 1530 Vassily the
third gazed out of the window of his
palace as a terrific storm battered
Moscow it was 20 years since the Grand
Prince had come to the throne 20 long
years in which had tried fruitlessly for
an air now nearing the end of his life
his desperation and got the better of
him
it divorced his first wife and remarried
scandalizing Moscow one religious man
had even prophesized that this evil act
would produce an evil air one who would
terrorize the country we can only wonder
if fastly the third was reminded of that
prophecy as he looked out of the window
at the storm that was wracking Moscow
the night that his son was born the
Russia Ivan the Terrible was born into
was very different from the one we know
today for one thing it wasn't really
called Russia but Muscovy or the Grand
Duchy of Moscow if you want to be old
fashions for another it was tiny
compared to modern Russia it was nothing
a landlocked strip hemmed in on all
sides by rival States but it was
something else too
the Muscovy of 1530 was weak the powers
of the day were poland-lithuania
which hadn't technically yet become a
fully joint state but was so close that
we're just going to say Poland Lithuania
to keep things easy and the carnage of
Crimea alongside them were a hodgepodge
of weaker Islamic carnage left over from
Genghis Khan's Golden Horde khanates
like Kazan and Siberia don't worry about
all those names they were gonna remind
you of them when the time comes just
note that at the moment of Ivan's birth
Muscovy was a tiny outpost of Orthodox
Christianity surrounded by a sea of
Islam and Catholicism not that this
concerned young Ivan very much he was a
baby too busy playing to care about
affairs of state that was what his dad
was there for so about that in 1533
Vassily the third contracted an
infection which swiftly turns him from
strong King into dying King sensing the
end was near the Grand Prince summoned
the boyars a class of warrior Nobles who
held much of Muscovy power Vasily made
them swear loyalty to his son Ivan
before setting up a Regency with a
second wife Eleanor ruling in Ivan's
name that done he promptly died shortly
after on December 4 1533 little Ivan was
proclaimed Grenn's Prince of Muscovy
while this sounds like every
spoiled Brad's dream the reality was
rather less glamorous from that point on
his mother Eleanor insisted he be
surrounded at all times by armed guards
in case the buyers tried to kill him and
assume the throne but Eleanor needn't
have worried that the buyers might kill
little Ivan why murder a child when it's
so much easier to simply replace his
regions on the 4th of April 1538 Ellen
had died almost certainly assassinated
by the buyers her death set off an
explosive power struggle in the musca
back court for Ivan this meant spending
his late childhood trapped in a
whirlwind of Cruelty the buyers knew no
limits like warlords they would do
anything to keep themselves in power in
one instance Ivan witness to mentor
being skinned alive for crossing a
powerful family it was also a time of
neglect Ivan would later recall that
despite living in a palace he wore only
rags and often had to beg for food the
only time the buyers cared about the
young grands prince was when some
foreign dignitary visited then - would
be dressed up and paraded around before
being dumped back in his guilt at prison
with all this cruelty around him it's
perhaps no surprise that Ivan began
taking out his anger on animals by the
age of 12 he was torturing cats much
like it witnessed the buyers torturing
their rivals but if the boyars thought
they could cowl the weak and useless boy
they were about to learn a terrible
lesson ivan may have barely been a
teenager but already he was plotting his
revenge
[Music]
on December the 29th 1543 a group of
guards marched into the quarters of one
of the cruelest buyers in Muscovy saying
they were following the grand princes
orders the guards arrested the man
dragged him away and fed him alive to a
pack of wild dogs
it was the middle-ages equivalence of
walking into the prison yard and
punching the biggest meanest skinhead
smack in the mouth aged only 13 Ivan had
just ordered his first gruesome murder
from that point on the boyars
they would show more respect not that
Ivan did the same for others around him
though by 14 the newly confident grands
Prince was wandering the streets of
Moscow with his teenage friends beating
and robbing any citizen unlucky enough
to cross its path yes it would be unfair
to say that Ivan was merely a thug at
the same time he was getting a taste for
brutality the boy was getting a taste
for something else too
Ivan was discovering religion around the
same time as his first murder Ivan had
fallen under the sway of the
Metropolitan known as Macarius who had
impressed upon Ivan the need for Muscovy
to become a bastion of Orthodox
Christianity and Macarius he knew just
how to do that in 1547 Ivan's Regency it
came to an end on January the 16th he
was crowned Tsar Ivan the 4th of all
Russians in a lavish ceremony overseen
by macarius this was a big deal
Ivan was the first person to be crowned
saw by using that title and using
Byzantine trappings in the coronation
Ivan Macarius we're positioning Muscovy
is the successor state to the lost
byzantine empire the defender of the
Christian faith they even began calling
Moscow the third Rome three weeks after
this audacious ceremony ivan held
another one On February the 3rd 1547
Tsar Ivan the fourth married a young
girl called Anastasia you've probably
never heard of her but you have heard of
her family Anastasia was from the
Romanovs in the not-too-distant future
her family was going to transform Russia
[Music]
but only after Ivan had had its turn no
sooner was the terrible on the throne
than he was firing off edicts reshaping
Muscovy with far-reaching reforms
surprisingly not all of these reforms
were terrible to go through all of them
would take forever but you can sum them
up as being largely about accountability
in the mid 16th century the era stir
crabs could generally get away with just
beating you to death in the street
simply because they felt like it Ivan's
new laws essentially said guys you can't
kill commoners for no reason at all not
cool it may not sound like much but
coupled with the introduction of
localised government and Muscovy first
professional army it was a minor
revolution still let's not kid ourselves
that Ivan felt bound by his laws yet
designed them specifically to weaken the
power of the boyars when a bunch of
commoners came to him to complain about
a corrupt official Ivan had all 70 of
them strips naked in the snow before
setting their beards on fire still by
the time his fifth anniversary on the
throne rolled around Ivan was in a
pretty good place domestically it
consolidated power won the public's
approval and weakened the hated boyars
now he just needed his shiny new state
to find a way of living up to that whole
third room thing and what better way
would be to do that than to launch a
crusade okay so now it's time to check
back in on all those neighbors that we
mentioned earlier here are the ones who
were left over from Genghis Khan's
golden horde well the last few years had
seen the carnage in Crimea growing
bolder tartar armies were starting to
hairy the fringes of Muscovy but Crimea
was far too strong for Ivan to deal with
right now
no he and Mark areas had their sights
set on somewhere a little closer to home
Kasim a minor Carnot on the Volga River
Kazon was technically a threat to
Muscovy but was actually a political
basket case that's not to say they were
helpless though over the years many
muscovite armies had tried to conquer
Kazan and just as many have failed now
he was secure in his position Ivan was
determined to show everyone just how it
was done On June the 16th 1550 - Ivan
the fourth rode out at the head of a
vast army since this was the first major
war it was imperative that everything
went well
to that end Ivan put aside hours per day
for praying begging me Christian God to
help him crush the Muslim infidels and
while it seemed that God was listening
on September the 2nd Ivan's armies laid
siege to Kasim they cut off supplies
destroyed access drinking water and
built huge earthen works to defend from
cavalry attack by early October it was
over Kasim fell on October 13th just two
days after Ivan's son Dmitri was born
although the carnage tried to return it
was effectively dead Ivan had done it
and not just done it had done it with
astounding ease had he died now it's
likely that Ivan would have gone down in
history as a great what if I ruler
history buffs singled out as someone
with the potential to be a legend this
is worth thinking about because in 1553
Ivan really did nearly die
bayar ivan fell deathly ill thinking it
was the end he did as his father Vasily
the third had done and summons the
buyers to swear an oath to his son
Dmitri this time though the boyars
refused they preferred eivin's cousin
if ivan really was dying he was just
going to have to deal with this being
the end of his royal line however ivan
didn't die he recovered but he came back
slightly changed always a paranoid man
Ivan felt like his illness had confirmed
his darkest fears the boyars really were
out to get him at that moment ivan vowed
that he would get them first
come Windsor 1557 Ivan was looking for
an excuse to expand Russia's borders the
year before is armies at annex the other
carnet on the Volga asked Kahn
this gave Muscovy clear access to the
Caspian Sea but all the victory had done
had convinced Ivan that his new Russian
state needed access to an actual sea one
the connected to riyals one like the
Baltic Sea in those days Muscovy was
boarded by something known as Livonia a
state roughly a now us to modern-day
Latvia and Estonia while Kazon had been
a remnant of the Golden Horde Livonia
was a remnants of the lands that the
Teutonic Knights had conquered but with
the Knights now gone and Protestantism
on the rise lavanya's Catholic rulers
were starting to look rather weak then
in 1557 King Sigismund of poland's
lithuania inserted himself in Slavonia
affairs forcing the nation to sign a
treaty with him for Ivan this flagrant
provocation was the excuse that had been
looking for the moments the atrocious
winter weather cleared up Ivan was
leading a full-on invasion force into
Livonia determined to carve a path to
the Baltic coast to say the war started
well is to miss just how easy of a
victory this was the new Muscovy armies
they steamrolled the livonians
by 1560 the livonian order was in ruins
and its Grand Master had been dragged
off to Moscow and executed it should
have been another easy win for Ivan
unfortunately though it was anything but
in 1561 a new Grand Master was appointed
for Livonia with commendable slyness he
surrendered not to Ivan but to
sigismund's thereby giving Poland
Lithuania a claim to the territory
Russia had occupied at the same time the
Grandmaster ditched his Catholicism and
invited the Protestant Swedes to invade
and restore order in the north and just
like that
Ivan found himself suddenly stuck
knee-deep in a war that would last for
the next 20 years and it couldn't have
come at a worse time
in 1561 Ivan was still reeling from the
double whammy of his son Dimitri's death
and the suspected assassination of his
wife Anastasia
although Ivan still had two heirs his
sons eivin the younger UNS the mentally
challenged Fyodor the sudden loss of two
family members is still left and very
bitter when metropolitan macarius too
passed away in early
1563 Ivan seems to have lost it that
same year he beat one of his own
soldiers to death the first murder thus
are committed with his own hands but it
was the events of April the 30th 1564
that would really make Ivan into the
terrible that day Ivan's best general
Andrey Kurbsky defected to the
Lithuanians this seems to applaud Ivan
raging the buyers were making a fool of
him he announced he would abdicate the
throne you might expect the boyars to
jump for joy at this after all this was
the guy who had had one of their number
thrown to wild dogs but this was war
if the Tsar left now the power vacuum it
created would potentially cause Russia
to implode the bars had no choice they
begged Ivan to stay in early 1565 Ivan
finally agreed on one condition that he
be allowed to create a new mini state
within Russia itself a place where he
would rule as a God without any checks
or balances backed into a corner the
boyars agreed and it was a decision that
would set Muscovy on the path to hell
but just before we get to that path to
hell i want to take a minute to tell you
a bit about Squarespace and there are
two things here maybe you've got some
idea for a website or a business or a
YouTube channel of podcasts or something
like that floating around in your minds
and the thing about that is you're only
gonna figure out if it's a good idea if
you do it and you get it out to the
world and it could always be scary to go
and do new things because well it's
always scary to do new things but not
knowing how to set up a website is not
an excuse for not doing them and
Squarespace they make setting up a
website super easy and they remove those
excuses Squarespace allows you to create
a powerful website for whatever you're
up to you want to sell something online
Squarespace can do it Podcast yes they
can totally organize that too or if
you're starting a YouTube channel you're
gonna want a website to complement it
and you can do that with Squarespace
it all starts on Squarespace with a
beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or you
can start from scratch or just move over
from an existing domain
everything is super easy to manage but
you know one thing one piece of advice
from me if you don't have design skills
I absolutely don't don't start from
scratch use a template it just makes it
easier like I said it just eliminates
those excuses for getting started once
you've gone through the super easy
customization process there are no
updates there are no patches there's no
tech BS to deal with and square
they also handle all of the website e
stuff podcasts like I say they do mail
in this social media and much more it's
all there
they also have 24/7 customer support so
they will help you whenever you've got a
question just head to Squarespace comm
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to Squarespace comm forward
slash buyer graphics and you will save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain let's get back to it
shortly thereafter Ivan divided his
nation into two parts the Zen stringer
was where things carried on us before
almost unchanged the oprich nina was
where Ivan's darkest impulses came out
to play the Opera Janina covered about a
third of Muscovy territory but it wasn't
as simple as drawing a line on a map
Ivan was allowed to choose what he
wanted in his new kingdom so naturally
he selected the richest towns meaning
the borders between approach Nina and
xem Chino were often rather blurred in
Moscow itself the border could change
street by streets and even house by
house you might never know when you were
suddenly subjects to Ivan's whims and
this was a problem because it wasn't
Ivan doing the operation his dirty work
it was the Opera Dicky an army of around
6,000 men the Opera Niki were
effectively Russia's first secret police
dressed in all black they rode black
horses and drove black carriages that
were designed to instill fear they were
completely above the law given the right
to torture rob rape or kill anyone they
felt like and to burn down whatever
buildings they wished burn as the
children of darkness they had one
mission to terrify the populace into
submission
you better believe that they succeeded
to relate every awful thing that the
opportunity did would result in this
video being about 10,000 hours long and
giving all of us PTSD so let's just
stick to examples like the palace they
used as the headquarters where it said
20 people were tortured to death every
single day or there's their sadistic
commander mo looter school rat of who
likes to rounds up married women from
across Moscow and have them all raped
for his entertainment with Ivan's
blessing the opportunity targeted by a
family is murdering or driving them into
exile seizing their properties that were
left behind by the ends of the 1560s
they're turned so many wealthy families
into refugees that the operation Ikki
had managed to set themselves up as a
new aristocracy but where was Ivan in
all of this he was leading from the
front in early 1570 for example Ivan
became convinced that the city of
Novgorod was about to join the lift the
onions there was no evidence for this in
fact Ivan had made his rapist in chief
Skuratov forged documents to prove
Novgorod was on the verge of rebelling
nevertheless On January the second Ivan
rode out at the head of a vast
opportunity army for the next month the
opportunity were allowed free run of
Novgorod killing burning maim
like some demented sixteenth century
version of the purge citizens were
hanged by the hundreds others were tied
up and dumped into the ice-covered river
those the managed to get back to the
surface had their heads caved in with
axes by the time the opportunity left
Novgorod on February the 12th there was
no Novgorod left in one short month the
operation he had killed anywhere between
6,000 and 12,000 people back in Moscow
Ivan followed this brutal pointless act
by accusing buyers of conspiring with
Novgorod and having them executed by now
there was this feeling that nobody and
Muscovy was safe and that the horror
would never end
however help was about to come from a
rather unlikely source the opportunities
end came suddenly in spring 1571 there
were rumors that a Crimean Tartars force
was marching toward Moscow but Ivan
barely bothered to prepare after all his
opportunity spies it told him the force
was a few thousand strong at best
in fact the advancing army contained
over a hundred and twenty thousand
soldiers by the time Ivan got the news
any chance to fortify the city it was
gone so Ivan simply grabbed as much
treasure as he could and he fled leaving
Moscow to its fate and well what an
awful fate it was the Tartars ransacked
the city Muscovites were dragged away
into slavery children were slaughtered
in their homes every single building but
the Kremlin was burned to the ground by
the time the tartar force retreated on
May the 26th over a hundred and sixty
thousand Muscovites were dead or in
Chains so many bodies had been dumped in
the river that had actually changed
course the next year Ivan abolished the
opportunity perhaps to cover his own
failings he also unleashed a new terror
against the operation Niki for failing
to protect Moscow paying back blood with
blood but it was a little use Russia was
by now a war shattered ruin with an
exhausted populace in an economy on the
brink of collapse perhaps the only
silver lining was that the Crimean Tatar
army had finally overextended itself
shortly after and was crushed by the
regular Russian forces still this only
offered limited respite
if by tvind were to save his nation
there would only be one thing he could
do Ivan would have to end the livonian
war but he didn't although it was clear
by now that his boneheaded in
of the Baltics that caused these endless
crises Ivan still couldn't give up his
old ways in the early 15 70s even tried
instituting a new reign of terror having
his opponents at home roasted alive but
his real enemy was the senseless
paranoia in his own minds while Ivan was
busy killing buyers Pollan Lithuania's
new king was invading Russia and the
Swedes were reconquering Russia's gains
in Livonia yes Ivan refused to listen to
reason no matter what happened he failed
to see that he himself was at fault
however while Ivan the Terrible was
having a truly terrible time his son
Ivan was doing rather better a capable
general Ivan the younger had fought the
Polish Lithuanian army in battle and
acquitted himself well so well in fact
that the boyars actually wrote to tsar
ivan saying can we have this dude
instead he's he's like much better now a
vein meant leader of the army but Ivan
the Terrible thought they meant to make
his son Tsar and this was a suggestion
that he didn't take kindly in November
15 81 shortly after receiving the buyers
petition Ivan stumbled across his sons
pregnant wife in a rage he beat her so
savagely that she miscarried when his
son came to complain the old monster
grabbed his staff and hit the boy around
the head with it and he kept on hitting
until his skull had broken and the floor
was slick with blood Ivan the younger
died of his injuries on November the
19th 1581 it said that tsar ivan reacted
to his passing by wailing my god what
have I done but it was even worse than
the puffed up sadist realized with Ivan
the younger is dead as Dmitri Anastasia
the last heir to the throne was Ivan's
simple-minded son Theodore in just a few
short years
Theodore's ascension to the throne was
going to both plunge Russia into chaos
and end Ivan the terrible's family line
for good
[Music]
if nothing else the death of Ivan the
younger seems to a finally focused
Ivan's crazed mind in 1581 the Tsar of
all Russians formally asked the Pope to
negotiate an end to his war with Poland
Lithuania the eventual peace process saw
Russia surrender all of its gains in
Livonia a separate peace with Sweden
sought Russia abandon its claims to
coastal towns on the gulf of finland
after 24 years of war after the deaths
of hundreds of thousands of people
russia was right back where it had been
in 1558 all that horror all that
suffering the operation inna all of it
it had been for nothing
the only silver lining had been the
destruction of the Carnot's in the early
days of Ivan's rain and the implosion of
the Crimean Army after it sacked Moscow
and the second of those had been in
spite of Ivan rather than because of him
interestingly enough
Ivan scored one other great victory in
the last days of his reign that had
absolutely nothing to do with him in
1583 the stroganoff family yes just like
the dish rode a private army into
Siberia almost on a whim and defeated
the carnate there this simple victory
would open up Russian expansion into
Siberia for centuries to come providing
a wealth of riches they would help bring
the nation back to its former glory
so I guess well done mr. stroganoff by
1584 Ivan was so ill that even leaving
bed for him was too much
his only solace was playing chess
something which he was doing on March
the 18th when a stroke allegedly carried
him off we say allegedly because it's
long been rumored that the tyrants are
was simply strangled by fed up buyers in
the aftermath of Ivan's death Fyodor
took the throne but was so useless that
his rule led to something called the
Time of Troubles a 15 year period of
civil wars and uprisings that made the
Opera to Nina look like Disneyland
constructed from unicorns in fact the
chaos Ivan the Terrible left in his wake
only cleared when Anastasia's old family
the Romanovs finally seized power in
1613 so at the end of all that then well
can we really say about the man known to
history as the Terrible well first of
all he absolutely lived up to his
nickname seriously next time someone
bang
on about how terrible is just a
mistranslation of Grozny just remember
that mistranslation or not terrible is
absolutely appropriate but there are
some darker lessons that we can take
from Ivan's story the idea of an
unaccountable leader who ruled through
fear and of a secret police run by
sadists with no real checks on their
power would return 500 years later and
perhaps the only Russian leader more
terrible than Ivan it said that Josef
Stalin
admired Ivan the Terrible maybe he felt
in him a kindred spirit calling to him
through the years encouraging him to go
even further to commit even worse crimes
than it happened during the operation
Nina it's often said that history
repeats itself well even the briefest
look at Russian history will show you
that Ivan's tale repeated itself again
and again like a record needle stuck in
a groove
Ivan may have been the first crazed
autocrat to terrorize Russia but he
would not be the last so I hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a like below it does
help us out and gets this video in front
of more people also if you really like
this please do so and you're not already
subscribed please do subscribe to our
channel and hit the notification bell
below also why not check out our sister
channel called Geographics its geography
obviously if this one is about people
that one is about places check it out
there is a link below and thank you for
watching
[Music]